avec nous Clément Gignac économiste
sénateur indépendant bonsoir
clémentignac bonsoir c'est un plaisir de
vous accueillir en personne sur d'autres
plateaux pour parler un peu de l'état de
l'économie des marchés et surtout on a
reçu en début de semaine prévisionniste
que vous connaissez bien et que il
connaît bien avoir Street François
truand qui nous a dit que le pire était
devant nous est-ce que vous partagez son
pessimisme sur l'avenir économique et
l'avenir des marchés également je pense
que ça vient de François Trinh faut
vraiment écouter parce que c'est une
personne réputé avoir Street est-ce que
le pire derrière devant nous ben je
pense que les prochains mois la
prochaine année ou à difficile est-ce
qu'on va vivre une dépression je ne
crois pas est-ce qu'on va vivre
l'Apocalypse je garderai cette
expression là encore de conflits
militaire mais ce qu'on va vivre
utiliser
un terme plus ou moins approprié je me
donnerai surtout une gêne cette première
universelle de la gare Ukraine je sais
moi pascalypse parce que l'apocalypse
c'est les images qu'on voit donc c'est
plus relié un conflit militaire et là
moi je expert de ce côté là cependant
est-ce qu'on va vivre une récession oui
en fait la dernière fois qu'on s'est vu
j'avais dit que je pensais que
l'inflation une réception excusez-moi
serait inévitable est-ce qu'elle sera
sévère comme 1980 ou 2009-2010 je ne
crois pas mais il y aura une récession
comme vous l'avez bien expliqué
qu'Olivier une récession s'arrête pas de
jour au lendemain dans un premier temps
c'est l'immobilier qui est vulnérable
autour qui est sensible autour d'intérêt
qui est premièrement frappé le second
secteur après on part du manufacturier
l'automobile qui est le prochain domino
à tomber et pour qui est vraiment une
récession selon les définitions surtout
que ça soit accompagné par des pertes
d'emploi une hausse du taux de chômage
et un recul des revenus des
consommateurs ce qu'on va observer sans
doute seulement en seconde moitié de
cette année mais là si l'inflation
repère à la hausse est-ce que
l'inflation va repartir à la hausse aux
États-Unis on voit ça au Canada on
semble pas aller là quel est votre
perspective en accélération de
l'inflation je pense que le sommet de
l'inflation on l'a atteint l'eau quand
on a eu le 8%
aux Etats-Unis ou 7 au Canada à moins
vraiment qu'un interruption du côté du
pétrole je pense qu'on est vraiment dans
un recul d'inflation mais c'est très
résilient et le repli va être modeste ça
va prendre du temps et si les banques
centrales veulent atteindre vraiment
leur site de 2% 2024 2025 ça ça veut
dire d'autres hausse de taux d'intérêt
sans doute que le taux directeur aux
États-Unis sera au tour de 5 et demi
possiblement on évoque même 6 %. alors
deux trois autres
minimum et là dans ce contexte là je
crois que là ça va devenir très
difficile parce que les gens qui
renouvellent leurs hypothèques ou ils
doivent changer leurs autos parce qu'ils
ont pris une location de taux donc tout
ça va frapper et vous l'avez dit il y a
des délais de 6 à 8 trimestre donc ça va
commencer à frapper est-ce que le père
peut venir disons que les prochains mois
vont être beaucoup plus difficile vous
me connaissez je suis optimiste de
nature mais je dois dire ce soir que je
pense qu'effectivement une récession
devient inévitable mais ça sera pas une
dépression ni d'apocalypse juste pour
bien comprendre les sessions aux états
certainement au Canada également au
Québec qu'on devrait mieux s'en sortir
que l'Ontario pour toutes sortes de
raisons premièrement le prix
d'électricité ici est contrôlée
par rapport à ce qui vous on va aux
États-Unis ou en Europe deuxièmement si
on regarde au niveau de des finances
publiques du Québec on est quand même
une assez bonne position et le Québec
est moins sensible aux consommateurs
américains que l'automobile que
l'Ontario qui est vraiment accès dans
les exportations de taux mobile vers les
États-Unis donc le taux de chômage au
Québec ne devrait pas monter trop trop
d'autant plus qu'on ne pénurie de main
d'oeuvre donc les entreprises vont y
penser deux fois avant de licencier des
travailleurs est-ce que la géopolitique
est importante on voit la guerre en
Ukraine puis toutes les tensions avec la
Chine selon moi oui je reviens de
Bruxelles où j'ai passé trois jours
comme avec 5 autres parlementaires au
niveau des rencontres à l'OTAN c'est
clair que le monde a changé comme nous a
été mentionné le mur de Berlin lorsque
tombé c'était pour le meilleur le monde
de changer bascul pour le meilleur à ce
moment-là c'est certain que voulaient un
an l'invasion de l'Ukraine par la Russie
amène un changement complètement et ça
ça fait que les chaînes
d'approvisionnement et ça pourrait
affecter aussi le mondialisation telle
qu'on la connaît surtout si la Chine
décide d'appuyer la Russie à ce
moment-là on va avoir toute une révision
des modes de chaîne de stationnement et
voir est-ce qu'on doit vraiment être
dépendant de la Chine au niveau de nos
approvisionnements vous n'êtes plus
stratège mais vous avez été stratège
longtemps quand vous regardez les
marchés boursiers et je reviens encore à
ce que François trem nous disons en
début de semaine le marché baissier ce
qu'on appelle le berm market n'est pas
encore commencé selon lui quel est votre
perspective de ce côté il y a des
rebonds je pense que en fait le marché
baisser selon moi on est un peu beaucoup
dedans quand on regarde puisque le
marché avait baissé de 34%, il y aura
Bondy d'environ de 20% depuis le
mi-octobre maintenant il recule écoutez
il y a une récession des bénéfices qui
s'en vient en fait elle est déjà amorcée
le marché se trans 18 fois les profits
prévus mais avec des taux d'intérêt
maintenant qui sont autour de 5% et non
plus à 2% et dans ce contexte là où les
banques centrales continuent de
resserrer c'est évident selon moi que le
marché boursier est cher et si on
compare au marché obligataire en fait il
devrait pas être au niveau actuel vous
l'avez dit je suis plus le stratège mais
comme conseil de bon père de famille ou
de grands papers je dirais au lieu de
penser qu'on met 60% en action puis 40%
en obligations j'aurais tendance
inverser cela que dans un contexte
actuel ou qu'on continue à monter taux
d'intérêt qu'on s'en va vers une
récession ce sera plus sage non pas de
toute liquider prendre panique que tous
les opportunités c'est fou vous devez
vous asseoir avec votre conscients mais
peut-être de prendre moins de risques
donc peut-être de favoriser un peu plus
les obligations qui sont devenus
nettement plus attrayantes que les
actions on apprécie toujours vos
conseils d'économistes vous aimez votre
job de sénateur oui ça se passe bien oui
et ça donne des opportunités parce que
c'est élargi les horizons comme là j'ai
passé Bruxelles à l'OTAN le 2 semaines
j'ai passé une journée honorade au
Colorado donc le géopolitique va donner
beaucoup plus important que ce qu'on a
connu d'intrants dernières années je
pense même comme économiste et sénateurs
ça va être au service des Canadiens
ouais ben ça va être intéressant en même
temps dans votre travail Clément merci
d'avoir été avec nous au plaisir pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez-vous
sur la chaîne ici RDI